today on the matt well show protesters
made a scene in my georgia tech speech
last night though further investigation
indicates that they didn't know exactly
why they were there or what they were
mad about no surprise i suppose also the
white house debriefed tick-tock stars on
the ukraine the ukraine situation and
now those influencers are dutifully
repeating the government propaganda
assigned to them plus some parents are
upset about the new pixar film claiming
that it's not appropriate for children
we'll take a look at their complaints
and see if they're justified and an nba
player complains that insults and
heckling from fans is causing him mental
pain and anguish now we've heard the
same thing from a number of female
athletes though the public reaction is
quite a bit different and we'll try to
figure out why that could be the case
and what exactly is public health equity
well it's more than a jobs program for
bureaucrats though it's mainly that but
it's more than that as well we'll
discuss that and much more today on the
matt wall
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
show you know we're living in a
fast-changing world and one of the best
ways to succeed in it is to learn how to
code uh you can't say this to people on
twitter anymore it's hate speech to say
learn to code but actually you should
learn to go so try codecademy today and
see where coding can take you whether
you're starting from scratch or looking
to advance codecademy can help you reach
your coding goals over 50 million people
already know that codecademy is the best
way to learn to code that's because
codecavity academy not only teaches you
job job-ready coding skills but also
helps you build unique projects for your
portfolio earn certificates and even
prep for your technical interviews not
sure where to begin well code academy
will point you in the right direction
take codecademy's programming
personality quiz to get tailored career
advice and course recommendations based
on your strengths and interests you get
instant feedback as well your code is
tested as soon as you submit it so you
always know if you're on the right track
you can build your portfolio get a
certificate of completion to make
yourself more marketable to future
employers so join over 50 million people
learning to code with codecademy
and see where coding can take you get 15
off your codecademy pro membership when
you go to codeacademy.com and use promo
code walsh that's promo code wall shut
codecademy.com get 15 off codecademypro
the best way to learn to code
c-o-d-e-c-a-d-e-m-y.com promo code walsh
so last night as scheduled i gave my
talk at georgia tech in the lead up to
the ncaa women's swimming swimming
championship where a biological male
will compete against
and dominate uh the females i wanted to
explain why this was wrong but i i
wasn't there just to talk about women's
sports i was you know there to talk
about and the whole speech is available
on my youtube channel as you'll see if
you watch it our discussion went far
beyond sports and into issues
surrounding language
biology logic basic fundamental truths
of life you know all these sorts of
things at one point in the speech i
spent about five minutes talking about
what the words male and female mean
and um explaining that men cannot have
babies and it occurred to me as i was
getting into this part of the speech how
sad and deeply tragic it is that we've
reached a point in society where a
podcaster without a college degree has
to go to colleges and give basic biology
lessons but that's where we are and
that's where i was last night
of course there were many students at
the school who did not want me there and
as we talked about yesterday the local
antifa chapter collaborated with the
leftists at the school to try and
sabotage the event based on what they
were posting on the internet it seems
that there was an attempt to reserve a
bunch of the tickets ahead of time
preventing people who wanted to actually
attend from from being able to attend um
but that plan proved futile as there was
a line stretching around the building to
get into the event and we ended up
having a packed house and it was a great
event um
the wannabe saboteurs were mostly
crowded out of the room
by the sweet baby gang which showed up
in great numbers
that didn't stop one guy from making an
attempt anyway about a minute or two
into my speech he stood up on his desk
with a rather bizarre sign and i think
that we were talking about this
afterwards and it seems as though
he thought
that some other leftist would join him
in this demonstration i don't think he
thought he'd be the only one but i i i'm
guessing they coordinated this ahead of
time and so okay we're all going to
stand up early in the speech and make a
big thing
and but nobody else did it was only him
um so we all just ended up having a good
laugh at his expense while he was
ushered out of the room rather quickly
but it was it was a lot of fun it was
good moments let's watch that here it is
well the most important thing to
establish for our purposes today is that
he is a man he is a he
and that will never change
that won't change
no matter what kind of uh
poster you hold doesn't change
that fact
at least the poster is laminated because
i saw some posters out there
i appreciate the effort
that's awesome so protesters out there
were holding signs on loose leaf paper
it's like come on
this guy he took the time to laminate
that thing with whatever that is
and i really appreciate it
like he had to go down to office space
or you know you had to go down to
the staples with that thing all right
anyway
leah thomas is a man back to the subject
in hand here
hey i did appreciate the lamination on
the sign i mean obviously took a certain
pride in the work and i commend him for
that um but he he did make a few
mistakes like typing the letters in
white with a pink background making it
difficult to read what the sign actually
said
the sign apparently made some kind of
reference to um quote femboy furry porn
now
i don't know what that is
that guy apparently does know what that
is and felt the need to announce it to
the audience he wasn't the only leftist
in the audience i should say there were
a few others who perhaps understandably
chose not to join the furry porn fan in
his demonstration instead they sat there
at their desks flipping me off at
various points throughout my remarks
shaking their heads in disapproval and
finally storming out of the room i
actually didn't notice any of this
that that even was happening i was told
about it later i didn't notice that they
marched out i just wasn't paying
attention to them the rest of the
protesters were outside being a bit more
vocal and explicit of course they
marched around with with signs uh
accusing me of being a fascist uh
chanting that i was killing children
somehow
they also reportedly chanted trans
rights are human rights for literally
five minutes straight i was told
um and as the attendees
people who were at my event as they left
they were accosted by the protesters
cussing them out and calling them
fascists as well
so to be clear
the audience members were fascists for
simply listening to what i had to say i
mean they they didn't even all agree
with me they just they just listened
and so listening to someone else's point
of view
is now fascism
because of course everything is fascism
at least though the protesters were so
that was that's kind of what you expect
fascist fu a lot of that kind of thing
the protesters were a bit more creative
with this chant though and i did
appreciate it play uh clip two
matt can't swim i mean first of all
that's a libelous accusation i i can
swim just very poorly it's more of a
more of a treading water sort of thing
doggy paddle kind of situation
enough that you know if one of my kids
is drowning i can jump in and save them
and i'm not going to drown alongside
them
but that's that's about as far as i can
go i'm just not sure what any that has
to do with the topic at hand
i wonder what insult they'll come up
with at my next event maybe they'll have
a chant mocking me for the fact that i
tend to overcook chicken breasts
maybe claiming that i i don't know how
to fold fitted sheets
both of those would be true by the way i
just i don't know i don't mean to give
them any ideas
in any case perhaps the most instructive
moment i thought came when one protester
who uh we should note put much less
effort into his sign
i think it looks like he stole a dry
erase board from one of the classrooms
and just wrote on the dry erase board
there's some efficiency there i guess
you can always change the message and
everything so i can appreciate that i
just i could have used a little bit more
color a little bit more flare in it but
um he was asked
by by someone who was there and twitter
account by the way is at rapid fire
underscore pod is the person who has
this uh got this footage for proper
attribution anyway asked like what what
is it about why are you here well you
know you've got this sign what what is
it that you don't like about this guy
what's the problem
and uh here's what he had to say i have
a sign over here that says
matt walsh tpusa talk to us about the
sign why is this important to you today
uh because i think matt walsh is an
idiot and dangerous to people
and yeah that's really all i have to say
on that number one thing matt walsh has
said that's pissed you off that made you
hold up that sign today oh god
i'd have to go back and look through his
twitter i know i see it all the time
just give me one i mean we're holding
the matt well shine just give me one one
thing i've eaten that while she's
consistently said that
um you know trans women are not real
women trans men are not real men when
it's proven by science that trans women
are in fact women trans men are in fact
men it doesn't have to do with
your born sex it is that you feel like
you are
a woman and that's okay like you don't
have to conform to what
the society society so if you decided
that you wanted to identify as a woman
today is that something that we would
label him as he's a woman at that point
she's a woman she's a woman at that
point got it got to use the correct
pronouns all right so we've got women
trans women aren't women what about you
are women well that matt walsh has said
that has made us hold this sign today
what about you what does matt walsh say
um let's see there's a lot of stuff
about um
january 6 like
honestly i get so confused with all
these right-wing tools it's hard to keep
track of who says what but i know i've
seen some stuff he said and i know i
wasn't a fan
i love how he's making no attempt to
project any confidence whatsoever about
what he says
um you know i don't like him because
matt walsh is an idiot i think
and uh
dangerous
right he's dangerous that's what we're
saying about him okay
he ends all of his statements like when
there's a question mark at the end which
by the way is a problem
in general with young people today if i
might say uh they all tend to speak as
if the ends of their sentences all have
question marks
uh but that's that's that's another
matter
but listen he he knows he's seen some
stuff that's the point and
he he knows i've he's he's seen some
stuff that i've said and it was not good
stuff
and that's all he needs to know
and he's not but most importantly he
knows that he's supposed to hate me and
so he does
also january 6th he throws in there
because everybody knows that i am a
famous supporter of the capitol riots i
i was actually at the capitol that day
doing uh doing a tap dance on top of
nancy pelosi's desk
i guess i shouldn't joke about that or
the feds are gonna bust down the door
any minute now anyway he was he has no
clue why i'm i'm terrible he just knows
that i must be the girl standing next to
him on the other hand at least quotes me
accurately uh she
is correct that i think trans women
aren't women because they aren't she is
of course incorrect in her claim that
science proves otherwise but one
attitude ain't bad
now
this all might seem pretty funny and it
is no question about that
but what's the point
of going into these environments and
kicking out the hornet's nests like this
as i mentioned yesterday my next stop is
going to be at unt where they chase the
last conservative speakers out of the
room
forcing them to hide in a closet
that's where we'll be going next now why
would i want to go there of all places i
mean why why do any of this what's the
point well one reason to go to these
places is that college campuses have
become extremely hostile to the truth
not just to open dialogue or to free
speech or whatever although it is
hostile to that as well of course but
for me that's not the main point the
main point is the hostility to truth
and wherever the truth is least welcome
is precisely the place where it's needed
most those are the places where we
should go
you know if you're talking to if you're
in an environment where
um
everybody agrees like everyone
understands basic common sense things
about biology and all of this
then some of these you know it's it's
still important to reinforce the truth
and to talk about it but
some of this wouldn't be needed but it
is
because of this hostility to truth so
that's one reason
another reason is that i'm frankly a
stubborn antagonistic kind of guy and
when people tell me that i can't say
certain things or go certain places it
just makes me wanna
go those places and say those things
even more but the other even more
important reason is that is that as i've
said before this is a very important
thing for us all to
to grapple with
that there is no
natural wake-up call coming
for these kids
okay the conservatives who've comforted
themselves with this notion
that uh it's just a bunch of silly kids
they're gonna get out into the real
world and and uh they'll wake up pretty
fast
the conservatives who think that have
been saying this for forever they're the
ones who are in for a wake-up call i
don't know why it hasn't happened yet
for them
these kids who are allergic to basic
truth
who chant fascists that anybody they
disagree with who hate people like me
even though they don't even know why
they hate me
these kids will be entering a culture
that is set up to keep them in that
state of delusion ignorance and fear
okay it has a a lot of older people are
in that same state
absolutely as we've seen especially over
the last two years but before that as
well
and so
we can't wait around for people to wake
up
we have to go to them and wake them up
which means being a little aggressive
and perhaps confrontational
and even even rude at times
because the only other option is to let
them and millions more
remain stupefied and hypnotized forever
because that's what will happen
now let's get to our five headlines
[Music]
you know when it comes to keeping the
house clean having a bunch of kids not
to mention having the dog in the house
it's kind of it's a it's a double-edged
sword because
they cause a lot of mess i mean a lot of
mess but then also
um you got to be careful about the
chemicals that you bring in to clean up
the mess because you have kids in the
home so that's why i'm so grateful for
naturally it's clean did you know that
you can get hospital grade cleaning
products that won't leave harmful
chemicals in all your surfaces
introducing naturally it's clean a home
cleaning company dedicated to providing
the most effective cleaning products for
your home while reducing the use of
harmful chemicals their secret powerful
plant-based enzymes which are nature's
solution to cleaning and when i say
powerful i'm talking about
hospital-grade enzyme cleaning power
naturally it's clean has safer chemistry
formulas to clean every area of your
home from the bathroom to your hardwood
floors for your to your kitchen all of
their products are manufactured right
here in the usa and they offer free
two-day shipping directly to your door
so try them yourself right now
my listeners get get their hands on the
naturally it's clean daily wire
essential kit stocked with four great
products for 15 off simply visit
naturallyitsclean.com and use promo code
mat
to um to get all of this try out these
incredible cleaning products in your
home today for 15 off by visiting
naturallyitsclean.com matt promo code
matt
to make matters worse um they did all of
that also of course i have to to mention
they did all all of this was going on
all this happened to the nation's most
revered and beloved and celebrated lgbtq
plus children's author i mean that's
that is just
that is that's the insult to injury with
with with all of this
it's not even safe
for the best-selling children's author
of all time
which is what i've decided i am now
to go to a college campus
um okay so i've got to mention this at
the top
i can't pretend this is the most
important news story we'll get to some
news it's maybe a little bit more
important but this this is just it's the
it's the greatest story of the year so
far so that's why i'm mentioning the top
of the five highlights so down in
australia um
the prime minister came up with
something called the women's network
which is and we're in we're in
international women's
i think this is women's month or women's
history month something like that um
because we've got we got women's history
day and international women's day and
all these but then you also have to have
the entire month as well so we're in the
middle of uh women's month and then and
so the australian prime minister came up
with this thing called the women's
network
which is supposed to quote promote
gender equality and support members to
succeed in their personal professional
lives
and um they had a logo that they came up
with for this which i'll let you see
here and i hope that you're watching the
video so that you can appreciate this
this is this is real okay this is the
logo take a look at it i want you to
look at that that's this is i had to i
had to double triple quadruple check
this because when i saw it i'm like
there's no way
that that cannot be real there's no way
that happened and it did this actually
happened
so if you're listening to the audio
podcast i will tell you that the logo
looks like i mean it looks like a
portrait of a man named richard it it
looks it is it is
it looks like it's designed to be
phallic in appearance it looks like a it
looks like a male you know situation and
it's it's a penis okay is what i'm
saying
that's a penis it's just what it is
for the women's network
now the logo had to be taken down and
it's going to be changed as you might
expect
and apparently this was not done on
purpose
now you might you might think that it
was done on purpose and that was my
after i realized that this was not a
joke my second thought was okay well
they must have done this on purpose
because they're trying to make the point
now
that uh so to speak make the point that
these days
women can have penises too and so maybe
this is what they were trying to say
this this was their not so subliminal
message getting that point across
but then they took it down so evidently
it was an accident they weren't trying
to do that
this thing was designed
and it went through however many levels
of bureaucracy
and and nobody
noticed
that it looked like a penis
okay this is a government thing that
means that that means that like
nothing ever just happened there's no
efficiency
nobody just does something and then it's
done
that probably dozens of people had to
sign off on this thing and none of them
stopped and said
you know what that looks a lot like a
penis that's what bureaucracy gets you
that is what bureaucracy is it can't
even identify a penis when it's right in
front of its face
all right
going to from australia back to the
united states where
um certainly our bureaucracy and our
government isn't any less incompetent
the white house convened a meeting this
was a few days ago with uh top tick-tock
influencers
giving them a briefing
on the ukraine situation this also is
not a joke they actually did this one of
the influencers was a girl named ellie
zeiler
who is famous for making eight-second
videos where she she dances and this is
of course on tick-tock this is there are
a lot of people have become famous on
tick tock for just dancing and not even
full performances but just eight or nine
seconds
and um anyway just as an example here's
one of the the videos of elizabeth's got
she got like 10 million fans okay this
is a massively famous person
and here she is let's watch
[Music]
so that
that's 10 million
10 million fans for that
now i'm no one to judge but but the
dancing isn't even
if you're at look people have been
ever since the the invention of modern
media there have been people becoming
massively massively famous because
they're good dancers
and i'll admit that i that there's a
certain bias for me because i don't
really understand that at all i don't
understand why anyone should get famous
and wealthy because they can dance i
mean who really cares that much
um but at least you know
30 years ago
you're you're famous for dancing and
it's like you because you're like
actually a really good dancer now that's
not even good dancing right that's
that's
am i wrong again i'm not a good judge of
this but that is very lackluster dancing
that is just barely a step above a
bridesmaid at a wedding in terms of
dancing skills maybe not even that good
and that gives you 10 million followers
that's it that's all you got to do just
do a couple of moves
five five six seconds ten million
followers and you're getting invited to
the white house
for a debriefing on uh foreign policy
while war rages in europe and so they
got the debriefing and now all the tick
tock influencers it just so happens what
do you know they met with joe biden and
now they're all making videos
and for many of them this is the maybe
the first time they've actually spoken
in a video because usually they're just
dancing
and now they're all making videos
explaining how all the bad stuff in the
world happening right now it's all
putin's fault it's it's definitely not
biden's fault so here's uh zeiler
filling in filling her fans in on this
crucial fact why is gas so expensive and
why is the united states inflation rate
at a four-time decade high
i had the opportunity to ask the white
house why gas down the street is seven
dollars and here's what they said
the obvious reason we are getting out of
a two-year pandemic when use goes up
price goes up but the call is
predominantly about ukraine and russia
so how does that relate russia is one of
the top three producers of oil and it is
actually their number one revenue source
now with putin starting this horrific
fight between ukraine and russia
nobody wants to work with him and do an
international trade so with people being
scared of war and limited resources
prices are bound to go up as well for
the people who can't pay seven dollars
for a gallon of gas there's an app
called gas buddy that shows you the
cheapest gas near you as well as a link
in my buyout to donate to the misplaced
refugees of ukraine
so first video she's made that was more
than eight seconds long i mean that for
for her what that because that's like 45
seconds
that is she might as well be reciting
war and peace this is this is her
magnum opus there's a 45 second video
and she's she's actually speaking
and uh and she wants to let us all know
that this is all this is all putin's
fault it's not i mean because it's not
biden's fault
gas prices and everything
even though gas prices were trending up
already
uh before all of this it's still all
putin's fault
we can't blame joe biden but remember
something else
all of these
other countries
countries that are autocratic
dictatorial
where you get a lot of propaganda
government propaganda
media that that parades around as as if
it's free and independent but really
it's getting all of its talking points
and marching orders from the media i'm
from the government rather um you know
we don't have that here we're we're much
better than that here we don't we don't
we don't do that right
no of course we do
and there's just there's just something
even creepier about it
when they're bringing we're used to this
from cable news we're used to the
government propaganda from cable news
and most of the people
watching cable news you you basically
know that that's what you're gonna get
okay so the people watching there are
only seven people watching cnn
um they're all 65 and older and they're
there because they want the left-wing
propaganda msnbc it's three it's
actually three people but they're from
the same group of cnn a few drop off and
we'll watch msnbc again but they're
there
because they want the propaganda
um
[Music]
and the buy administration knows that
well okay we've got we've got pretty
much the entire media except for fox
that will that's at our beck and call
they'll do whatever we want
um
you know we blow whistle they'll come
running along like dogs and do what we
want to do and that's that's great for
them
but it only goes so far because of the
people that you're accessing
now you want to get to younger people
you want to get the kids
people that aren't really prepared don't
understand what they're being told
uh they're just there for the dancing
videos they're not really there and
prepared for the propaganda makes them
more susceptible to it actually
that's what the administration is doing
all right this is from the daily wires
the west virginia legislature on
saturday sent the bill banning abortions
of babies over a down syndrome diagnosis
to the governor's desk the west virginia
house of delegates passed the unborn
child with down syndrome protection and
education act in an 81 to 17 vote on
saturday the state senate passed the
bill 27-5 with just five minutes left in
the regular legislative session uh the
measure now goes to the desk of governor
jim justice as a republican we can
assume it will be it will be planned
um the bill prohibits
abortions of an unborn baby due to a
physical or intellectual disability
unless a physician can show that this is
that the disability is not the mother's
primary reason for seeking the abortion
the legislation is also requiring
doctors to provide educational
information to parents of an unborn
child who has just been diagnosed with a
disability like down syndrome
lawmakers in both chambers attempted to
add a more general abortion ban to the
bill that would have prohibited
abortions after 15 weeks of pregnancy
but that measure failed planned
parenthood of course called the abortion
bans cruel and dangerous
and they say that it's going to harm the
health and futures of americans
alex mcgill johnson alexis mcgill
johnson the president of planned
parenthood action fund said with this
bill politicians have exploited people
with disabilities and attempt to
distract us from their real intent to
ban abortion in west virginia
now what you think about that for just a
second
her claim is that people with
disabilities are being exploited
by a law
that makes it illegal to kill them
so i'll say that again people with
disabilities are being exploited by a
law
that makes it illegal to kill them
that's exploitation to protect them from
murder is exploitation
what i mean what do you expect from from
planned parenthood these are
these are uh some of the most evil
people who have ever lived on planet
earth and that is not an exaggeration
because
what they do for a living is commit
fund facilitate
the mass murder of babies and they've
killed 60 million over the course of um
or the abortion industry in general has
killed 60 million planned parenthood
specifically has killed tens of millions
over the last 40 years
uh there's never just there's never been
anything like it on earth there have
been
there have been genocides there have
been mass slaughters there have been all
kinds of horrors but
um 60 million children being killed
specifically
and that's been a time nothing like it
has ever happened
never been anything like this so these
are
deeply evil soulless people uh who will
just say anything they don't have they
have no capacity for shame it doesn't
matter to them so they'll even claim
somehow
that this it's cruel and dangerous to
say that you can't kill down syndrome
people now
as far as the bill itself
um
you you can point out that
in in effect like what's the actual
effect of this going to be
like is it is it necessary do we need
these kinds of bills well absolutely but
we need a ban of abortion across the
board
obviously um
but also when it comes to
children with down syndrome they are
especially
targeted for extermination
and you look at some european countries
there are almost no down syndrome people
left
because they're all being exterminated
in the womb
this is an actual genocide that's
happening
against a group of people
so there obviously should be laws
protect them but you you look at the
language in this law
and the fact that um well you know you
can still get the abortion of the down
syndrome child as long as a doctor will
say
that it's not because of the
the the down syndrome
so
in effect it means that it's not really
going to stop anybody from getting the
abortion because you can any any woman
can just go to a doctor and say uh yeah
i wanted abortion for any like any other
reason just whatever but for financial
reasons anything
and the doctor will just sign the letter
and that's it and they can still get the
abortion
so
it's probably not going to stop any
it's it's it's hard to see how it'll
actually prevent
any of these murders from from happening
and also
you know
we know that these these bans on
abortions again should be much broader
than it should protect down syndrome
kids but also all kids
um
still i'm i'm of the opinion that
do anything you can do any any any laws
at all that you can pass
restricting abortion to any extent
whatsoever you should pass them that's
that's kind of where i fall on this
there's always this debate about
incrementalism versus
an all or nothing philosophy and i just
don't see how you can
side with anything other than the
incremental approach for now as long as
as long as you're not satisfied with
that so you pass this bill this is the
bill you can get past right now keep
fighting for the next keep keep fighting
to get the next bill out there
as long as you're not satisfied
now where i would oppose bills like this
that you know if if they improve the
situation they only approve it in a very
minor way i'd only oppose it if it means
that this is all you're going to do and
now you're going to rest on your laurels
and say that well we did it we did all
we could do as long as the fight keeps
going but whatever you can pass pass it
whatever you can do right now whatever
you whatever can happen right now to
protect as many kids as possible do it
and then tomorrow do something else
and from a political
from a from a political perspective
it also puts democrats in the position
of our you know let's let's let's
actually put
let's you're on the hook now
okay ball's in your court
are you actually going to take the
position
that it should be explicitly legal to
kill down syndrome babies because they
have down syndrome
as we know many democrats have no
problem saying yeah i should i think
that should be legal but a bill that
forces them to come out and say it is
good also for that reason
force them to take the mask off
that's another good thing about some of
these abortion bills
um even if some of these bills you know
the number of abortions that they're
actually going to stop is somewhat
minimal
if they if they force democrats to take
the mask off
and show their monstrous face then
that's another that is also another
benefit
all right
uh
this is from daily wire also it says
turning red is the newest movie from
disney pixar that has some parents
turning red with anger they say the
children in the movie are overtly
disobedient and rude plus there are
sexual themes including the main
character twerking as a panda in front
of her mother while taunting her plus
multiple instances of the girl rebelling
against her overbearing chinese-canadian
mother to the point of being
disrespectful
the film is talented touted as a
coming-of-age sensation where the
supernatural and the mundane happily
walk hand in hand
the rod tomato synopsis says turning red
in turning red uh
ma mae lee miley is a confident dorky 13
year old torn between staying her her
daughter's her mother's dutiful daughter
and the chaos of adolescence and as if
changes to her interests relationships
and bodies body weren't enough whenever
she gets too excited she poofs into a
giant red panda
the movie's rated pg is intended for
slightly older audiences compared to
other pixar films especially since it
deals with subject matter of puberty
specifically however even considering
the target demographic some parents and
reviewers are insisting the project goes
a few steps too far and what's worse
that lacks the charm inherent to so many
other disney pixar projects i've heard
this criticism of this film
as basically summarizing what we just
read there um that it's just this
obnoxious kid disobedient to her parents
it doesn't actually have a message of
course you can
portray that kind of stuff in kids
movies been portrayed many times before
but the question is what's the what's
the message at the end of it
um
and there is no from what i've been told
there is no message at the end of this
telling kids okay well actually you
should respect your family is important
you should respect your parents
that's not the message at the end in
fact the message is quite the opposite
of that and then also apparently um so
this is a this is a movie about a girl
going through puberty
and turning red and the fact that she
turns into a
red panda is a not so subtle metaphor
for that
um and so that's part of the the theme
of this movie and then you think well
who who is it actually
is this is this a pixar movie about a
panda is for 13 year olds is that who
this is for
because when you think about pixar
movies like every other one that's been
made you immediately think okay well
this is for five and six year olds
maybe other people can watch it too and
enjoy it but that's that's who it's for
um a movie that deals with well this is
specifically about a girl going through
puberty
i don't know who is it so this is a
pixar movie specifically for 12 and 13
year old girls that doesn't make a lot
of sense to me but look i haven't seen
the movie
i don't plan on seeing it
um i've heard enough just from this
that uh
my kids aren't going to watch it i do
put a lot of stock in kind of parental
reviews those are the i tell you what
those are the only reviews i actually
care about the only ones that i trust
and i find to be relatively reliable
um i rotten tomatoes aggregate scores
don't really mean anything
even the aggregate audience score to me
doesn't mean much
the fact that a bunch of critics liked a
certain movie that doesn't mean anything
okay uh the fact that the audience
broadly liked the movie also doesn't
mean anything because if you go to
rotten tomatoes look at the aggregate
audience score for pretty much any
marvel movie it's all gonna be like 99
percent people raving about how
wonderful it is and the movie is
terrible um what i what i do care about
what i do read especially before i put
anything on for my kids if i'm not
familiar with the content myself is uh
you know you go to some of these sites
and you look at the
what are parents saying about it what
are the parental reviews and i find
those to be
most of the time pretty reliable
and this is all i need to hear you know
if you've got a large number of parents
saying this is not good for kids it's
got the wrong messages it's on top of
that it's just kind of loud and
obnoxious and stupid
um that's enough for me to not show it
to my kids
and i think we all need to be a lot more
discerning as parents what we let our
kids watch
especially when there's no real like
sacrifice in being a little bit more
discerning i think there are a lot of
parents who will just basically put
anything on for their kids and they
almost never tell their kids no when
they want to watch something but it's i
mean why what what's the what's the
downside if you're more discerning and
you tell your kid okay well we're not
gonna watch this movie and it turns out
that the movie was fine and they could
have watched it
how are they hurt by that they've still
got a million of the things they can
watch it's not gonna hurt them
even if you stop them from watching
something that would have been fine it
doesn't cause any damage to them
but you let them watch things that they
shouldn't be watching and you make a
habit of that then there is some real
damage to that
and as i said it's not i think it's an
important
detail here
for me as a parent when i'm deciding
what my kids can watch
uh yeah i'm worried about what are the
messages what are the themes
what are what what kind of things are we
dealing with in this movie i'm not going
to put a movie about
uh puberty on for my six-year-old okay
so i'm i'm thinking about that i'm
worried about that but also
just
is this
taking all the messages aside even if
the messages are fine and relatively
innocuous
is it just a stupid loud obnoxious dumb
thing
and it sounds like this movie is that
there's a lot of kids movies that are
like that a lot of kids shows that are
just dumb
loud
bright noises
or you know bright bright colors loud
noises and all that's all it is and it's
just obnoxious and stupid and it yeah
there might not the moral messaging
might be fine it might be as i said
innocuous
but it's making your kid dumber your kid
becomes stupider
in ingesting all this stuff all the time
this constant media diet of dumb dumb
content
and it detracts from their attention
spans it makes them so they can't pay
attention to things it makes them so
they you know they they constantly need
stimulation coming from a million
different directions and all of that
that's enough of a reason for me
all right
one other thing i wanted to uh mention
and i bring this up because there's a
revealing contrast here yesterday we
talked about the tennis player naomi
osaka who started crying in the middle
of the match because one fan heckled her
briefly
and then she got on the mic afterwards
stealing the spotlight from the winner
of the match
and uh and she cried some more that's
the other thing you see about these
female athletes who whether it's someone
biles or osaka are always crying all the
time and complaining and everything
they're also
they're also they're taking the
attention away
from the other players and also taking
attention away from the people the the
the players who actually succeeded
so she did that she was crying about it
and
everyone especially in sports media
is on osaka's side as usual talking
about her mental health and how people
need to be nicer to her and yada yada
but consider this when contrasted
against another professional athlete nba
player russell westbrook now
i don't follow basketball anymore but i
do know that westbrook has been
struggling this year quite a bit on the
lakers maybe before that playing you
know frankly just playing terribly he's
just not he's not playing well and the
fans are
ruthless to him the media is ruthless
and they've come up with a name for him
too which is actually kind of a funny
name and it's unfortunate what his last
name is because it works perfectly so
the name they use for him now and the
fans are chanting at him all the time
and the media uses it is a russell west
brick
so that's what they call him and a
couple days ago after another game where
he didn't play very well and people were
calling him westbrook he's um he's doing
his press conference
and he's asked about this and he talks
especially about the west brick
nickname and talks about how hurtful it
is to him and his family let's listen to
that my family has reached a point to
where it's really weighing on them um
and it's very unfortunate
just for me personally because
um this is just a game this is just a
game this is not end-all be-all and
when it comes to basketball i don't mind
the
criticism of missing and making shots
but
the moment it becomes where you sh
you know my name is getting shamed um it
becomes a a issue um i've
kind of let it go in the past you know
just
because it never really bothered me but
um it really kind of hit me the other
day honestly i was i mean my wife was at
um
teacher parent conference for my son um
and the teacher told me she's like
noah
he's so proud of his last name he writes
it everywhere he writes it on everything
he he tells everybody he walks around
and says
i'm westbrook westbrook that's his last
name
and it kind of i kind of sat there in
shock and it hit me like damn
like i can no longer allow
people um you know for example wes brick
to me is now
shaming like it's shaming my name is my
legacy for my kids
yeah so
that's
he's upset about the nickname and he
talks about how it hurts his uh kids
feelings and he doesn't he doesn't like
it
uh but you look at the reaction to this
from the sports media especially and
just the public at large
and there's there's just no sympathy for
this guy whatsoever like nobody cares no
one is no one is saying in fact i looked
at some of the headlines after this uh
one of the headlines yesterday why has
russell westbrook been such a disaster
for the lakers
russell westbrook a hypocrite for west
brick complaint it's just that kind of
thing right uh everyone kind of agreeing
well suck it up dude you're you're
playing terrible this is what happens
deal with it there's no sympathy i
didn't no one is talking about his
mental health no one cares no one's even
no one's even talking about his kids
mental health
and i i tend to agree with them right
you're a professional athlete um i'm
sure you've talked a lot of trash in
your day yourself in fact i know
specifically this guy has and this comes
with a territory you know and if you
really can't hack and you can't deal
with it um
then then you can quit and go do
something else with your life you get
you got a money a lot of money and you
can go do anything else and you'll be
fine and your kids will be fine
this comes with the territory when you
decide you want to play basketball in
front of tens of thousands of fans if
you play poorly they're going to boo you
and you got to deal with it
now the detail about his kid and how
this affects his kid he's not as proud
of his name anymore that actually you
know that's that's sad to hear that that
actually is said um and i can imagine
from
the kid's perspective right if now he's
getting taunted because of this and
but even so
you know that's
what else can be done about it this just
again it comes with the territory so
what are you gonna do start throwing
people out of the stadium you have no
choice as the adult
as the man the grown man to just deal
with it
sticks and stones and all of that
so
that's fine that's how i see it
and that's how everybody sees it
it's just you you see this contrast
between that and anytime it's a female
athlete with the same complaint
okay if this was a female this is a if
this if this is a wnba player talking
about the way that she's taunted and how
it affects her kids everybody would be
saying she's a victim this is terrible
her mental health is a serious issue
they put her on the cover of magazines
now she's she's actually doesn't matter
if she's playing poorly they'd make her
into the athlete of the year
because of how she represents uh mental
health
the real contrast there
real double standard and you know what
i would be fine with it actually
if it was in the context of society
admitting
that men and women women are different
i'd be fine with that i'm fine with
saying to men hey get over it okay
toughen up buddy
and then to women it's you know women
take this stuff a little bit more
seriously and they're more sensitive
and so i okay i understand that
i'm okay with that because men and women
are different and so i'm okay with
treating them differently
but the problem is that in is that
we're very selective
in our society about when we decide to
treat men and women differently
and even when we decide to treat them
differently we never admit that that's
what we're doing
and why we're doing it
and that to me is the problem
let's get down to the comment section
do you know their name
this is from mike dutton says if
breaking down and crying over every
little thing is courage my
three-year-old granddaughter is the
bravest person i know well yeah i've got
i've if that's the case that i've i've
got four kids who are
very very courageous there should be
statues built to them in their courage
um
causia says matt's ruthlessness has a
way of snapping people into reality
sometimes i'll find myself thinking oh
that's harsh when it comes to these
things and then i hear matt explain it
and i remember what it's like to have my
head on straight
uh you know i i don't consider myself
ruthless that's not the word that i
would use but
blunt i don't i don't care if you you
can use that word doesn't offend me but
i think of it more as just being blunt
directed to the point
and yeah i think that we that's what we
need in our society now i also think
that there's room we get into this
debate especially among christians all
the time
and i get criticized especially by
christians because they say well my my
approach is not christ-like and it's not
the right thing for way for christians
to approach things and i've talked about
that and i've addressed that and they're
just wrong in that
claim but
another thing that i say when that
subject comes up is that
uh people have different personalities
and it takes all kinds and so there are
different approaches to everything
and so not everybody so i'm gonna i'm
gonna take the sledgehammer approach
um
almost all the time that's how i'm going
in like a sledgehammer that's what i'm
gonna do
i don't think that everybody all the
time can be a sledgehammer people have
different approaches to things but i do
think
and there might be there might be
situations where
the sledgehammer is not the best tool
i'll admit there might be situations
where the side chamber is not the best
tool and yet i'm going to run into the
sledgehammer anyway and start smashing
things so i i get it and you know
um
but it has to be a tool in the arsenal
you can't you can't throw it out
completely
especially in our society today when as
like we talked about at the top people
are stupefied in a haze hypnotized
and sometimes to get somebody awake is
you got to slap him around a little bit
metaphorically
if not literally on occasion
um let's see
uh
earth child production says matt you
should definitely add a section to the
show for great historical figures or
facts that were not taught in school i
really enjoyed that section i'm glad you
enjoyed it i wasn't sure if i was boring
people while i was talking about it but
um these i i don't know how it could be
boring considering it's what we talked
about yesterday with the um
the story of ernest shackleton and the
endurance is one of the most fascinating
stories in history but there's just so
many
that the
it's almost cliche to complain about
these days but the the history education
that kids get in school is is
woefully lacking and of course
the education they receive on every
topic is woefully lacking but in history
especially if it's been that way that
this is not a new thing it was that way
when i went to public school
it's been that way for decades
entire sections of history are
completely ignored
many of the the greatest heroes of
history are ignored
and that that trend is only getting
worse
um
and it's and it's only going to continue
getting worse
especially as crt
uh
and kind of left-wing racialism infects
the school system more and more uh now
it's well we can't talk about ernest
shackleton because he was a white guy
you know he was a white british guy in
the early 20th century and he almost
certainly had views on things that
we would not find acceptable today and
even if he didn't
we have to find more diverse heroes
because if we talk about ernest
shackleton that's going to make all of
the all the kids who are not white males
feel left out so we can't talk about
them we got to find somebody else
um
chris says matt i know you're fully on
board with desantis in 2024 how would
you feel about tulsi gabbard as his vp
i know she has or still is technically a
democrat but i think it's safe to say
she's not on that team anymore
look
tulsi gabbard is
great
a really great
leftist i mean she's really great for a
leftist
as far as leftists go
she's about as good as you're going to
get
but she's still a leftist
that's what she is
and she's still beholden to that
ideology on when it comes to most things
i mean that could change i suppose
um but as of now she still left us and
no i would not
want a leftist on the ticket personally
let's see
honest 12 says the microwave is
literally the most futuristic invention
in my lifetime i'm 51 years old we were
promised much more when i was a lad
jet packs space trips unlimited food
human human-like robots to clean cook
perform sex
nothing more amazing than the microwave
has materialized though name something
more amazing than cooking food instantly
sorry i'm just stuck on you using the
phrase perform sex
are you a robot also is this how you
talk to your wife but yes might we
perform sex this evening
i just i can't get past that but anyway
look now you don't need there's there's
nothing how about i'll flip this around
on you
what is it that a microwave does
that
all the other tools
and appliances in your kitchen can't do
okay that's that's you don't need the
microwave ditch the microwave
also microwaves cause cancer i don't
know if that's true at all it just seems
like it probably is
don't put the misinformation label on me
i'm just i'm saying it seems to me i
feel as though they probably cause
cancer
daily wires constantly working to bring
you the truth that's why we've launched
our own publishing wing dw books and
we're proud to be publishing books that
are actively fighting the left's
monopoly on storytelling the first is 12
seconds in the dark by sergeant
mattingly and it's available right now
the book is the true story of what
really happened the night of the brianna
taylor shooting a lot of lies are told
about this but this has the truth and
you can check out for yourself the
trailer right now here it is it was very
chaotic it was very quick instantly i
knew i was shot brianna taylor she was
caught in the crossfire of those bullets
as soon as your brain's registering it's
already over the media got so many
things wrong in this case saying we had
the wrong apartment her name wasn't on
the warrant she was shot and killed in
her sleep in her bed these are lies this
is not true and all the while you're
hearing all these outside influences
from athletes and oprah and ellen
degeneres and kamala harris and joe
biden all those people coming and
attacking you putting your name on their
account saying he should be in prison
all these things that they have no idea
what they're talking about but they have
such influence the more we attack police
for doing their job the less good
qualified police you're going to have
when you read 12 seconds in the dark you
will find out the truth of what really
happened the night of the brianna taylor
raid
[Music]
in a world where voices like this are
censored the story is incredibly
important that's why the book is
available now on amazon or anywhere you
buy books online so go to so go order
your copy today um again amazon you're
not gonna want to miss this order it now
also another thing you don't want to
miss the premiere of our latest film
well if you did miss it it already
happened um but you could still watch
the movie the hyperions it's a
dysfunctional family film with an 80s
aesthetic and it's definitely worth the
watch here's the trailer if somehow you
have not seen it by now
calling all hyperions
[Music]
my name is vista mandelbaum
my brother and i have taken four
hostages everybody against the wall
we've come for one thing
our titan badges
is this real yes ma'am
it's the police they want to talk to
whoever's in charge
this titan badge can grant an individual
superhuman power
perhaps it's time for someone else to
take on the responsibility
meet apollo
i'd recommend next time using your power
yeah i mean yeah if you think so
calling all hyperions
on my way
you're making such a mess in here
we've got a hyperion in roots not a good
time to look stupid
shots fired
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
she's trying to destroy me
next question how's the family the
family is um
oh
gosh what is it
marvelous
[Music]
hyperions is now streaming at
dailywire.com so if you're not a member
yet now's the time to join plus if you
join right now you'll be entered to win
the red carpet treatment with you and
the cast and the crew of uh terror on
the prairie star gina carano if you win
you'll get flown out to the red carpet
premiere of terror on the prairie where
you'll meet and greet the daily wire
folks and the film's castle crew as well
two lucky members will each get two
tickets and their hotel flight premier
car service and exclusive merch all on
us you don't want to miss this head to
dailywire.com red carpet and sign up
with code red carpet to be entered don't
worry if you're already a member just
head to dailywire.com red carpet to
enter anyway now let's get to our daily
cancellation
[Music]
so one of the latest innovations of the
leftist bureaucratic class is the
concept of public health equity
now it's a sort of monstrous
amalgamation of the concept of public
health on one hand and equity on the
other concepts which existed apart from
each other for only a brief period of
time before they were combined of course
as soon as health equity was invented
related government agencies and
departments started springing up like
weeds all over the place and we now have
health equity departments at every level
of government with towns and counties
across the country racing to add their
own
as one example erie county in new york
recently set up its own health equity
office and they just hired a woman to
run it
here she is introducing herself to the
public listen
developing the office of health equity
and building a team dedicated to
improving the health
and quality of life of our most
marginalized residents is an opportunity
of great magnitude
the most vulnerable people of our county
face systemic challenges often called
social determinants of health that can
be addressed through policy programs and
people with the will to face those
challenges directly
meeting and overcoming those challenges
will define the work of our office
as we develop pilot programs
partnerships and services with our
allies across nonprofit organizations
health agencies and more
now if all that sounded like a bunch of
nonsense it was i mean what you have to
understand is that primarily concepts
like health equity exist to provide jobs
to useless bureaucrats who have no
skills and can't contribute meaningfully
to society
um again you know staying on erie county
as announced
you'll you'll um
you'll see you'll see how this this
works because
we can we can go back just a few months
to when this office was first announced
just to see how it works reading from
buffalonews.com
it says the issue of health disparities
in buffalo and erie county is an old one
but the question of what to do about it
keeps getting new answers the latest
answer is the creation of a new erie
county office of health equity which
will expand the county health department
with an additional nine full-time jobs
those salaries will initially be covered
by federal american
uh rescue plan dollars but will result
in future recurring costs county
executive mark
polankars called the new offices of
health equity a necessary expansion of
the area's african-american health
equity task force he pointed to that
group's role along with community
partners and successfully shrinking the
racial disparity in coven 19 deaths
continuing a little bit later it says
when the american rescue plan money
became available poland cars agreed to
devote a chunk of it to personnel
devoted to addressing the health gap the
office also will have a separate
advisory board comprising experts on
minority health who can provide insight
and recommendations to the members of
the new health equity director
while the county allocated three million
dollars to the african-american health
equity task force last year baskin said
outsourcing the action plan to address
health disparities isn't a permanent
solution the new office's role payroll
will exceed 300 000 in new salaries that
will eventually be a part of the
county's recurring costs okay so you see
how this this works government
bureaucrats
had some money to throw around
so they decided to and this is what the
you know american rescue plan
accomplished just gave a bunch of money
to a bunch of bureaucrats
and uh they said well i guess we gotta
use this for something and so we'll just
use it to create jobs for ourselves so
they decided to create jobs for
themselves and also for their friends
and
now even though there was already an
african-american health equity task
force there will also be
an office of health equity and these
will be in addition to all of the other
local groups focused on health equity
like the university at buffalo community
health equity research institute and
others like it now
so you have a bunch of
agencies and bureaucracies and
everything focusing on
racial health equity
and
all kind of doing the same thing
which is nothing and none of this will
achieve anything none of these people
will actually do anything
but that's the great thing about
something like health equity it's such a
broad and ambiguous concept
that there's there's no way to prove
whether the people tasked with enforcing
health equity are actually doing their
jobs or not and this is the case really
with any bureaucrat it's set up this way
that it's almost impossible
to know whether they're doing anything
from the public's perspective it is
impossible we certainly can't know but
even if you're in the bureaucracy
you're kind of looking around like is
anyone doing anything what's anyone
doing here
now you you take that problem and apply
to something like health equity
and the problem's even more pronounced
now meanwhile we should note erie county
is one of the unhealthiest places in the
country i mean actually unhealthy
physically unhealthy and this applies to
everybody not just marginalized groups
so-called it has an obesity rate of 65
percent as just one marker
now you would think that the attention
would be focused on an actual tangible
universal problem like that and we don't
need a health hack we don't need to make
more agencies
for this
but we've got a real health problem and
so let's address that
that's not what health equity is all
about what health equity is all about
besides creating jobs for useless
tax-funded bureaucratic parasites i mean
it's hard to move past that because that
truly is almost the entire reason why a
concept like this even exists but to get
to the whole picture i think we have to
break this down a little bit
so first of all you have equity
what is that
to get a sense of what equity is uh
supposed to mean anyway we can check
with camilla harris who offered i think
a um
pretty succinct explanation she doesn't
do a lot of succinct explanations but a
pretty succinct explanation of what
equity is supposed to be
back during the 2020 campaign let's
listen to that
so there's a big difference between
equality and equity
equality suggests oh everyone should get
the same amount
the problem with that
not everybody's starting out from the
same place
so if we're all getting the same amount
but you started out back there and i
started out over here
we could get the same up but you're
still going to be that far back behind
me
it's about giving people the resources
and the support they need so that
everyone can be
on equal footing and then compete on
equal footing
equitable treatment
means we all end up at the same place
[Music]
so equity
is not
not giving people equal opportunity it's
making sure we all end up at the same
place as she said equality of outcome
ensuring that nobody is ahead of anybody
else
equity is in fact the exact opposite of
the traditional american notion of
equality you know the idea behind that
sort of equality was traditionally
giving everyone the freedom to live make
choices struggle and strive ultimately
you know and
sort of establish whatever sort of
existence they can build for themselves
and there are some nuances there
obviously
people can't be free to make literally
any choice they want but that's the
basic generalized idea of equality
equity is totally different it's the
exact opposite equity militates against
equality
equity ruthlessly suppresses if need be
um equality to make sure that the
outcomes
are the same for everybody
and notice something about equity and
this is really important
it only cares about disparity
okay that's the only thing it's worried
about
equity doesn't care if people are
miserable suffering whatever it only
cares
that everyone is miserable and suffering
the same
i mean she doesn't even say
well we all we all want to make sure we
end up in a good place no we all have to
just end up in the same place doesn't
matter where it is
we could all end up in hell but as long
as we're there together hand in hand
then we're good
now introduce public health into this
and you've got a real problem um it's
clear enough that public health already
has nothing to do with actual physical
health that's why these public health
ministers tend to be
themselves personally pictures of
unhealthiness
they're so often obese apparently
deficient and various vitamins
generally not healthy at all
as people
that's because public health is not
related to physical health in fact
public health very specifically ignores
many of our greatest actual health
crises like obesity because trying to
fix obesity means telling people that
you shouldn't be obese and that's body
shaming and fat shaming you can't do
that
um
that's why public health is now sort of
an umbrella term
and i think now simply things that are
in keeping with public health
are those behaviors and ideas and
opinions and statements
which our ruling leftist class condones
that's what public health is
those things that are not in keeping
with public health are things which are
you know the things which are injurious
to public health
are behaviors ideas opinions statements
which are which the ruling class
condemns
and it really is as simple as that
so you take this concept and you merge
it with the marxist idea of equity
and you have just the perfect
frankenstein monster
because remember again public health is
it it's everything it encompasses
everything
anything that you're doing
that the left doesn't like is a problem
for public health
to include any statements that you make
any opinions that you have
and
now you put equity into it
again it's a perfect frankenstein a
monster which which will be somewhat
limited in the damage that it can cause
only because of the incompetence and
laziness of the bureaucrats who take on
these jobs but there's there's little
solace to be taken in that
and i suppose little solace in saying
though we will say it anyway
that health equity is today
cancelled and we'll leave it there for
today thanks for watching thanks for
listening have a great day godspeed
[Music]
the matte wall show is produced by sean
hampton executive producer jeremy boring
our supervising producer is mathis
glover our technical director is austin
stevens production manager pavo valdoski
our associate producer is mckenna waters
the show is edited by robbie dantzler
our audio is mixed by mike coromina and
hair and makeup is done by cherokee
heart the matte wall show is a daily
wire production copyright daily wire 20
22. john vickley here daily wire editor
in chief wake up every morning with our
show morning wire where we bring you all
the news that you need to know in 15
minutes or less
join me and my co-host georgia hal for
daily coverage of all the biggest
stories on morning wire